donc voila c'était bien qui nous a été
traitée on va l'ouvrir tout de suite et
dans cette boîte la boîte ils devaient
présenter avec un petit message
d'accueil du fondateur de valve nice
il explique qu'on va aller explorer les
merveilles de l'univers
donc voilà télescope donc on va sortir
c'est doucement il vient avec une petite
housse de protection
hop
vous y allez
ce moment mais c'est pas trop fragile
hop
26 coop
[Musique]
pape il est fourni avec un trépied qu'on
me reposer on va venir clip et nos
télescopes par dessus
poser comme ça il faut faire en sorte
que la petite bulle qui citait une
petite boule de niveau faire en sorte
qu'elle soit dans le cercle la petite
bulle au centre
tu peux la voir
[Musique]
oh
cela vient tout simplement
fixée
le truc a tout simplement
thaçi
[Musique]
l équipe est
pour alimenter le télescope une batterie
externe simplement qu'on va venir le gué
en usb inter du télescope
à l'intérieur
[Musique]
comme ça
on peut
[Musique]
saleh
donc y'a plus qu'à lui même
ici
pas seulement
ensuite vous connecter avec votre
application c'est évident ça c'est la
page d'accueil se connecter on va aller
le chercher dans le résolution
on est maintenant connectées au
télescope for revenir en arrière
et on peut lancer l'initialisation de
stamina
là le télescope cherche s'est buté à
droite et à gauche
puis il s'ouvre
et il a cherché une zone étoilé
[Musique]
oh
ensuite on va pouvoir aller chercher des
apps dans l'objet en cliquant sur ce
bouton la la il recommande des objets
observés sur lesquels il rapporté tout
seul en haut à gauche
le temps de pause conseiller pour
observer l'objet se déposent assez longs
toujours c'est normal ça nous oblige à
ses lointains ou assez ténue ensuite
quand on clique sur l'objet par exemple
à legrand hamadi recul là on peut voir
son élévation par rapport à l'horizon
alors c'est symbolique 1 on va dans
l'intérieur chélation exacte et dans la
direction laquelle il se situe kelly à
l'ats roger ps dont on clique soient
matés recul par exemple on voit qu'ils
conseillent 15 minutes dans deux
captures qu'il a 60 degrés au-dessous
l'horizon donc très haut
voilà je voulais symbolique il n'est pas
à cette hauteur là par rapport à
l'horizon c'est plus un symbole ce qu'on
veut dire que quand il est gênant quand
le rond et voilà c'est au-dessus il est
très beau il est très haut
l'azimut on sait la direction dans le
plan
là le télescope n'est pas encore utilisé
on souhaite avoir une petite fiche qui
décrit le grand-am à des reculs
c'est un amas qui contient 500 mille
étoiles sur un amas globulaires on peut
avoir plus de détails sur les amas
globulaires la situation la découverte
la distance la taille
la magnitude de la brillance ce qui va
permettre de patienter pour
l'observation
[Musique]
à
oh
où
[Musique]